uh this was a hard video to make
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be taking a look at the
controversial
reality tv show my 600 pound
life but first let me tell you about my
sponsor billbar
i have been in a built bar routine
and i have a build bar now like most
days of the week
often as like a little bedtime snack but
there are just so many different
delicious flavors i
don't think i will ever get bored now i
am admittedly running low
as i await my next box so hopefully i'm
gonna make it but
today's flavor what are we gonna try
let's go fruity with the carrot cake and
walnuts should we microwave this one
we should microwave this one hello
i like it for like 10 seconds
mmm that carrot cake it's like full on
carrot cake and there are pieces of
walnuts
there's definitely chocolate all over my
mouth but this one's got 18 grams of
protein
and because it's a lower sugar bar
usually i like to pair it with
some fruit or some ice cream don't judge
me
but it is freaking good with ice cream
especially when it's melted like this
but i just see it as really a convenient
and obviously super
delicious way to get your protein fix
for those really busy days
so if you want to check these out check
out my link in the description
and use my promo code to get 15 off of
your order
okay so before we get into this feel
free to pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a
big trigger warning to those with
current or previous experiences with
disordered eating
also i want to specifically call out
that i will be touching on
topics like childhood abuse and sexual
assault and weight loss surgery and
binge eating disorder so
please skip this video if that is not
supportive to your journey
also don't forget to subscribe to this
channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode
alright so for those of you who have
never
watched or are unfamiliar with my 600
pound life
this is an american reality tv series
that showcases
the weight loss journeys of individuals
living with
morbid obesity the show gives us an
in-depth look at
how the subjects navigate their lives at
their
size and documents their attempts to
lose weight in order to qualify
themselves for weight loss surgery
sounds more or less like any other
reality weight loss tv show right
well not quite while my 600 pound life
might market itself as being
inspirational entertainment
the unethical treatment of cast members
and the harmful depiction of people in
larger bodies
have me pretty concerned so let me tell
you just
a few things wrong with this show
starting with
problem number one it perpetuates fat
phobia
and voyeurism now it's no question that
fat phobia is
rampant in our diet culture riddled
world
so it's really no surprise that it's
used as a tool for entertainment
purposes
and just the concept of my 600 pound
life
is evidence of that fat phobic curiosity
is
certainly a driving force behind the
popularity of the show
especially given that it's one of the
top rated shows on the tlc network
and has aired a total of nine seasons
plus a follow-up where are they now
series
and when you consider the fact that the
weight loss industry is worth
billions of dollars it's no shocker that
this
would translate to major tv ratings
while tlc has built a name for itself
as a network that showcases people who
live outside the societal
norms my 600 pound life is particularly
exploitative and voyeuristic for
instance
participants of the show are strongly
defined by their morbid obesity
and ability or inability to achieve
their weight loss goals
their size and subsequent weight loss is
essentially the only aspect of their
identity that
we get to explore and is really the
entire
focal point of this entire series unlike
other
shows on the network like little people
big world or
sister-wise for example we totally miss
out on
who these people are outside of their
obesity
we just see them defined as just obese
people who fit into
a discreet category of success story or
failure the show also paints a
particularly negative and
dark portrayal of participants while
also exposing the
very intimate details of their traumas
and day-to-day life struggles
and i just find this portrayal often is
disrespectful and
undignified with that said it's no
surprise that the format of the show
fuels voyeurism or hate watching i mean
judging by a lot of the reddit threads
i've seen on the topic
a lot of people aren't watching it for
the heartwarming
moments or happy endings and rather than
showing the humanity of the participants
of the show
because yes these are real people with
real feelings and real lives the
participants on
my 600 pound life are instead portrayed
as
something that non-fat people should
seek to avoid
at all costs this is highly problematic
as
it perpetuates the weight bias and
discrimination that
people in larger bodies experience every
single
day psychiatric disorders like binge
eating disorder
require serious medical and psychiatric
care
and while you don't hear the
participants condition framed this way
on the show as i don't know maybe it
would incite
greater empathy from viewers than just
suggesting that
they are the size that they are because
they're eating themselves to death
it's very likely that there's a lot of
that going on
so i just think that profiting off of
the exploitation of obese people with
significant trauma for the sake of views
is just gross and not okay
and this brings me to my next point it
dismisses the
important connection between trauma
and obesity so a common thread among
participants of my 600 pound life
is childhood trauma whether it's sexual
assault violence drug addiction
broken families etc it's very clear that
the cause of their obesity and reliance
on food as a coping mechanism
is strongly linked to their childhood
let's take a look at just
one of many examples and another trigger
warning
this one is in the context of sexual
abuse
and i felt like i had no one to protect
me
so i started to turn to food to deal
with it all
sadly this outcome is unfortunately not
uncommon with studies suggesting that
the risk of obesity increases with abuse
and
childhood trauma in fact one large
retrospective study found that
66 of participants with obesity
experienced
one or more types of abuse another study
found that individuals with a history of
childhood sexual abuse
are more likely to be hospitalized for
psychiatric treatment
after their weight loss surgery this is
likely because
the surgery removes their primary coping
mechanism
because they are physically unable to
eat
larger quantities of food this may also
speak to the fact that
obese adults with histories of abuse
tend to lose
less weight after surgery compared to
patients with
no reported history of abuse on the flip
side
weight loss can actually be highly
triggering for individuals
who have lived in larger bodies for the
majority of their lives
they may even view their bodies as like
a protective suit of armor
that has helped to shield them from
further abuse
and while weight loss is certainly
desired in these cases
it can simultaneously cause negative
emotions to bubble up to the surface
so when you remove not only the physical
protection
but also the coping mechanism you can
imagine just how
vulnerable and emotionally dysregulated
one might actually feel now the
deep-rooted long-term effects
of childhood trauma can be particularly
challenging to overcome
as it negatively impacts brain
development
during a very critical period of growth
more specifically trauma can make the
brain
less responsive to rewards meaning that
it can inhibit an individual's ability
to experience positive emotions this can
increase the likelihood that abused
children will become clinically
depressed or rely on
unhealthy coping mechanisms as adults
whether that be
drugs alcohol gambling or in this case
food
so you can understand why gaining
enormous amounts of weight
does not usually happen simply because
somebody
loves to eat it's also not a sustainable
solution to suggest that somebody simply
eat less and exercise more if the
underlying trauma
is not being addressed this speaks to
the critical importance of
unpacking childhood trauma in order to
get to the root cause
of the eating behaviors start the
process of healing
and develop healthier coping mechanisms
it also speaks to the importance of
medical professionals being trauma
informed especially when treating
particularly
vulnerable populations like this without
trauma-informed care
weight loss attempts with or without
surgery may not be sustainable
in the long term now while i appreciate
that my 600 pound life
does shed light on the devastating
impacts that childhood trauma can have
on obesity
the show could certainly benefit from
creating a
more empathetic and thoughtful dialogue
around these topics
issues like binge eating disorders
childhood abuse
and depression are not to be taken
lightly
participants of the show who experience
these very serious
mental health issues deserve to be
treated with dignity and
care so that they can overcome their
trauma
and improve their quality of life which
brings me to
my next point it provides inadequate
emotional support as discussed there is
a
clear link between obesity and mental
health so in order to achieve
any long-term weight loss success there
absolutely needs to be
an ongoing emotional support system
to help heal the root cause of the
extreme weight gain
and this needs to be done through an
empathetic and compassionate approach
from all members of the healthcare team
unfortunately there often seems to be
more of a tough love approach going on
particularly from their surgeon dr now
whose bedside manner leaves a lot to be
desired
let's take a look so what seemed to be
challenges with your eating habit i
think my biggest challenge
is my mobility is it's hard for me to
stand a lot
so i usually just grab whatever's
quick and easy quick and easy come on
seriously
you're telling me if you were able to
move you would eat better
had some trouble with cravings still and
it's just a repeating record in my head
that plays over and over and over until
i give in
what is the complaint saying i want
chocolate i want chocolate i want
chocolate i want chocolate
so chocolate is more important to you
than living
apparently now i get that this is
television
and also that some of you watching may
feel you actually prefer this noble
approach although the evidence says
generally speaking
it's not helpful for most now food
cravings and mobility challenges for
example
are both common concerns that deserve to
be listened to
validated and addressed with compassion
but shaming and
guilt-tripping someone for their
emotional and physical challenges
does nothing but fuel the guilt and
shame
that they already feel it's also not
a helpful solution in fact this tough
love approach
often ends up fueling the cycle of
emotional eating
that probably got them into the doctor's
office in the first place
remember it's not a matter of being able
to
just stop eating if you really wanted to
food is these people's primary coping
mechanism
so if you as a healthcare professional
are inciting an
emotional response through guilt and
shame
the likelihood of these people turning
to food to cope
is actually very high but unfortunately
the messaging of the show
tells a very different story and
perpetuates the long-standing belief
that
obese people are lazy and lack willpower
and are therefore completely responsible
for their body size
think of it this way telling someone
with obesity to
just stop eating is like telling
somebody with depression to
just cheer up or someone with anxiety
like me to
just calm down when i am anxious those
words
just calm down turn up the volume
tenfold on my response
without understanding and treating the
root cause of morbid obesity through
adequate emotional support the wound
will
remain open and food will continue to be
used
as the coping mechanism but do the
producers of the show
really care about that well obviously i
can't speak for the sensibilities of all
the producers on the show but
i will just point out that there have
been 10
lawsuits that have been filed against
the production company
the majority of which claim that the
show did not provide
adequate mental health care or
sensitivity training for staff
purposefully causing emotional distress
for the sake of ratings
and they did not cover medical expenses
which
by the way can really rack up anywhere
from 15 to
35 000 for gastric bypass surgery
in fact according to online news sources
one cast member claimed to have
reached out to the production team about
being in a dark place during
filming and was told to fake it
till he made it not only that the show
also came under fire in 2020 for
continuing to film
during the pandemic and putting the cast
and crew
at risk despite working with a highly
vulnerable group so some might argue
that the production team is
not particularly concerned with the
physical and emotional well-being
of their cast members but hey it makes
good television
right and that brings me to point number
four
participants are portrayed without
dignity
one of my biggest beefs with the show is
the lack of dignity
with which cast members are treated and
portrayed like i mentioned
earlier we get a very intimate and
uncensored view of their day-to-day
struggles
one of which is the mandatory nude
shower scene for whatever reason every
participant of the show
must be filmed in the nude tending to
their hygienic needs oftentimes cast
members are unable to fit into a shower
or they are bedridden and have no choice
but to bathe themselves with a sponge or
they're bathed
outside with a garden hose like you
would bathe a dog
so i'm not going to show the actual
shower scene
but they actually do in the show i mean
the woman is
fully nude outside on her deck
do these scenes really add value to the
story
no it absolutely does not do
participants
really feel comfortable exposing their
naked body parts for the sake
of our own warped viewing pleasure i'm
going gonna go
on a limb here to guess no
many cast members have expressed their
extreme discomfort
and even a hatred towards their bodies
even
some going so far as to say that they
don't even look at themselves in the
mirror
so you can imagine just how
uncomfortable
it must feel to be filmed in your most
vulnerable state by a whole film crew
for the whole world to see unfortunately
opting out of the mandatory shower scene
is apparently not an option some
participants have even come out to say
that the production team would
manipulate or
threaten them if they didn't comply for
example
former cast member amber rachty was
quoted as saying the following
about her unethical treatment on the
show when i would say
i had a boundary that i didn't want
crossed their first reaction
was always to threaten to postpone or
cancel my surgery
i know that the field producers don't
have that power but they appear to be
using
this tactic a lot on non-compliant cast
members which
is next level unethical the very first
producer i worked with tried to use this
when i said i didn't feel comfortable
showering in the nude on camera
needless to say it didn't work and so
there i am filmed in a pink sports bra
and briefs
in my opening act this was my first
experience with the company which
is a hell of a rough introduction when
i read things like that i have to think
that the production team prefers to
treat cast members like
some kind of farm animal for her own
sick
viewing pleasure rather than as
dignified
human beings who deserve to be treated
with empathy and respect
i'm trying not to get worked up here but
let's close off on number five
that it positions weight loss surgery as
a quick fix
now there's no denying that weight loss
surgery can be a viable solution for
folks
who are struggling with obesity as
research has consistently shown
that it can help patients lose anywhere
between 50
and 70 of their excess weight and when
it comes to individuals with morbid
obesity
surgery can certainly make all of the
difference to improve
not only the physical and metabolic
consequences
of obesity but also improving their
overall quality of life
and we've seen just how impactful
bariatric surgery can be
in the lives of those featured in the
where are they now
series so let's take a quick look
everything about my life is better
mentally physically emotionally just a
different person now
so i'm completely focused on making more
and more progress
so of course this is really encouraging
to see however it's important to note
that
weight loss surgery is not a one-stop
shop for long-term weight loss
and it's not without its risks i talk
about this in depth in my video on
weight loss surgery risks and benefits
right here
but to recap the rate of weight loss
tends to decline
a year or so post-op while other
patients may
actually experience a lot of weight
regain one study found that the weight
regain rate was around 14
5 years post-op and that 40 of patients
maintained
at least 30 percent of their weight loss
after 12 years
just 40 percent now in addition
weight loss surgery may also cause major
complications
and nutritional risks so clearly this is
not a perfect
one and done procedure it's also
important to note that weight loss
surgery is not
brain surgery so if the underlying
psychological issues are
not addressed before and after surgery
the risks may
actually outweigh the benefits and put
someone on the path to
regaining the weight right back while
the show has only
now begun to mildly emphasize the
importance of therapeutic work
while also prescribing diets and
exercise regimens
i just want to strongly emphasize that
there is no
quick fix for weight loss whether that's
surgery
a crash diet or otherwise unfortunately
for most people
casually watching a 30 minute program
it might appear that to be the case my
hope is that the producers
at my 600 pound life will take the cast
members health
and well-being just as seriously if not
more seriously than tv ratings and views
morbid obesity is a serious condition
with very serious consequences
and should absolutely not be exploited
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today folks
thank you again to buildbar for
sponsoring this video
if you liked it be sure to give it the
thumbs up
leave me a comment below about what
you'd like to see me review next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye